[Music]
It's on the head.
Probably the most important move
on the second.
Okay. So, what we're going to be
concentrating on is uh harmoniz movement
basing
entire body. Now,
the good thing about
I think that differentiates style from
smack off.
The thing that different differentiates
style from other styles or at least
they're used to is they utilize
strongholds and that really
uh forces you to harmonize your body
movements. Right. So if he's just
blending with me, I can do anything.
There's no pressure on me to get things
right. If if he's holding strong, I just
try and
if I just try and move anyhow.
um I can't basically so I need to just
move in a unified way
in a very calm way
and
this produces
it changes how your mind works
and then while I do this morator after
that before every lesson and kind of
realize it's really important. The other
thing I do is it's a bit more subtle
is I connect to him here.
Okay. So, I'm just I'm kind of extending
it. You can just feel if it's sens.
It's not
it's not it's not really hard. It's just
enough
pressure. He's actually pressuring.
He's pushing side and back like that. So
just using that and he will sort of push
against that to some degree.
Just do things like it's just a little
bit extra. Okay. So just subtly
try and
reach into that or even that way makes
slightly sense but try to join his
center my center if his center joins to
my center
I have control I'm center I'm
So when I do techniques,
I work I kind of work them out as
it's not just me, it's him as well.
Yeah. So
we become one
unit, one biomechanical unit.
So while I'm looking to move his
structure with my structure so he
becomes
um the extension of me bit like with
with a sword becomes an extension
hopefully
you kind of doesn't matter if you got
the sword or you haven't got the sword
and it sort of starts to come same with
another person you kind of try. So just
try that and uh just try and feel this
connection there. It's just subtle.
Yeah. Sleep reacting to it.
Yeah.
Now, if I got too much in making fire.
So, it's got to be kind of sub.
This is what we're going to be looking
at.
You could be looking at trying to
connect
and then use that connection to control
not in a kind of forceful way in way
that allows you to move.
Straight down.
So he holds
And he should have control of me. So I
can't.
Okay.
So he should
so he's not control
but you know he's trying
much stronger.
Relax. Extend it towards you.
So while he's doing that, this is
what I didn't realize about this thing
for a long time. He's punching here. So
this is a really strong exercise to
build your center. Yeah. All these horns
we do, they work center. I came across I
came across uh there's a form of
bodybuilding where they just use muscle
tension. Okay. So they basically just
tense muscles they build these enormous
muscles without lifting any weight. Now
if you talk about strength I people
don't like it talk about key and stuff
but you have to build your core up and
your core is a muscle whether you like
it or not. The thing is to build the
core up that gives you stable center and
then you use the core
through your tendons through your sk sk
sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk
sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk sk
skeletal st st st st st st st st st st
st st st st st st st st st st st st st
st st st structure right so
eventually this becomes the powerhouse
and it operates through
structure body through tendon and that's
a lot stronger than
muscles
And whenever I talk about strength,
always talk about it's not talking it's
not strength. It's it's not it's not
really the right word because it's
it's not the same thing as
being strong.
So he should control my center. So I
can't give you. So there's a little
twist there.
Yeah. I just
extend into that. Now by doing that he's
connected to my center. Yeah.
So
I can pretty much do what I want,
but it doesn't help when you try and do
this. You know, the first time you got
some gorilla sort of
pulling your arm. So
I'm just move that move to the side
here. And I've done so
behind you. I'm also leaning on him a
bit. I'm shifting into his space. Yeah.
So, he's quite unstable at this point.
If I try and go through him here, he's
still strong. So, I just go up
here around this.
So, it's relax.
So,
come from
my hip turn
behind cuz he's quite tall. That's he's
quite strong here. So I need to
move into space a little bit. Raise the
sword
[Music]
again doing this way.
But when you start if I try and do
something doesn't work you know like
it's not strong movement. I won't be
able to move it. You'll be too strong.
He's got two arms against me. Yeah. So,
I just need some
looking away in case his feet come up.
Me in the face, but you
This is hard exercise to understand, but
it's it's kind of essential one. It's
essential for building up your core and
a lot of a lot of clubs will all
move into this straight away and then
you don't get this
don't get build up. So you can kind of
remain
further down when you started doing the
one star.
uh
soon as you started getting these hot
stronger holds you went to other clubs
and it was kind of very noticeable
difference and that's the main one of
the main things and then it sort of
builds from there.
It's not it's not about strength. about
moving everything together.
It's kind of hard to understand
[Music]
here.
Testing my posture. Test my posture
Bring back down.
I'd like to shove.
See
I can show
on hold strong
without bringing your shoulders in
obvious difficult it is most people find
it so I didn't really follow it so I've
been teaching people be easier scrolling
every
understanding what I'm
It's kind of like
this is kind of like a meme
to me.
I want to share it with him. Share share
this energy.
No, not energy. You're not having it.
You're not having this energy. Okay.
Share. Share your energy. Oh, that's
good. Right now,
I'll do that. But raise the soul. Raise
the sword. Yeah, that's good. Yeah.
There. Relax your shoulders.
That's how you do it. Good.
Okay.
Yes. That's it.